الابد هو الان معرض فني عالمي يجمع بين
الفن المعاصر وعراقه المواقع التاريخيه
المعرض الذي نظمته مؤسسه ارض جده الثقافيه
المصريه للعام الثاني على التوالي بهدف
عرض وتقديم اعمال احد عشر فنانا عالميا في
منطقه اهرامات الجيزه
27 في فنانين كثير قوي بيتكلموا عن الرابط
ما بين المعاصر او النهارده والحضاره
المصريه القديمه
وضعها في شكل نقاط متتاليه معلقه الهرم
خوف الاكبر مستلهمه روح قدماء المصريين في
الدم بين العماره القديمه والتقنيه
الحديثه
اسمه كده او المقصود به الهرم لما يديني
بمصطلحات اخرى غير المصطلحات بها الهرم
الاصلي وده جزء من مشروع كبير انا شغال
عليه اصلا له علاقه بتطوير شكل العماره في
مصر من بعد انتهاء العصر المملوكي فكره
الساعه الشمسيه في العصور القديمه كانوا
بيستخدموا الساعه الشمسيه كانها بيبقى في
زي عندي شكل معين وفي دائره ومن ضل الشمس
على الشكل نفسه بتعرف الساعه كم انا كان
بالنسبه لي ان انا عاوزه اعمل ربط ما بين
كيمو الجديد وعاوزه اخد من الحضاره
المصريه القديمه وكل ما يمثل بيها واحاول
ابسط قوي لدنيا دي وابليزانتت او اعرضها
بطريقه
معاصره وطريقه جديده هذا المعرض الذي
يستهدف الترويج للفنون الثقافيه العالميه
والاثار المصريه على حد سواء اجتذب عددا
كبيرا من الزوار من مختلف الفئات العمريه
اضافه الى التاكيد على رؤيه العالم نحو
الحفاظ على البيئه ومواجهه التحديات
المناخيه من خلال استخدام مواد يسهل اعاده
تدويرها بشكل امن